now have you Joe and Carol ever been the
same place together no we've never have
I've never met Carol Carol's been
attacking me viciously for decades this
lady has just had a thorn that she's
just been stabbed with it has my name on
it I guess she's always been after me
even though our place is literally a
hundred times nicer than hers
bigger more beautiful incredible set up
such great healthy beautiful animals
Carol's really had a very hard time
showing anybody anything but a derelict
run-down junkyard of a place I mean it
places across America I've seen I've
seen hundreds of them versus the worst
one in the country you know there's no
places back woodsey funky is that Joe
had way too many animals in way too
tight of his face he had some nice
habitats and a few things set up but
mostly at a dog pound Rose habitat after
habitat after habitat to small and the
animals are boxed up you know so I've
never really got to deal with Carol at
all except in ascending her
notifications from attorneys to take
down images and letters and ideas that
she's put up a few times and Joe I met a
few different times through the zoo
industry he was trying to improve his
facility was contacting people that I
was helping out about how to have better
food how to have better habitat how to
build things better I'm for the big cats
talking about that and then five six
years ago he came to Myrtle Beach and he
actually cuz Myrtle Beach is a tourist
town with 20 million visitors and there
was a big circus show in town go
supplied some Tigers for that circus
magic show and they had trouble where
they were keeping them what was
happening people were complaining so we
went down and looked at all of it said
hey what five thousand song :
and we can help you with bigger space
maybe get your animals outside do
something else for you and the show
closed down but in the interim I had to
deal with him a few times
waiting to dinner with him one time just
to talk about it next door to them the
big theater that was here in town and I
had you know that was my biggest joy
experience during that time his staff
were all around and they came through
our attraction the murder
Safari and they saw the attraction and
took tours it he was like that's what I
want I need to build a place to exact
reference a lot of people think that
we're friends somehow he says I'm his
mentor which I think I'm mentor to
people all over the world who want to
build world-class facility because ours
is just of that scale and we've had the
time and opportunity to put tens of
millions of dollars into a single place
which makes it have a lot of Flash and a
lot of incredible habitat that if you're
if you're the best in your world who's
the second best in your world there's
single habitats that are really well set
up at several zoos you know that I've
seen got it the stuff they do at Busch
Gardens in Tampa is a beautiful setup I
think there's several places that have
built great setups but nobody else does
what we do the other place I see
personally it looks beautiful
over and over the name right is likitha
Coons place who is the president King
whatever it is of United Arab Emirates
he has an incredible facility there it
looks like you know he's dropped a
hundred million on it I mean it's it's
exquisite and the animals look
incredibly well cared for
I have mutual friends who work there and
and live there and I think that that
place is a world-class
[Music]